与其我自己心里面生闷气，
委委屈屈的，
我还揣着个孩子委委屈屈的去生气，
不如我把丑话说在前面，
我就是没有安全感，
钱就是要存在我卡里，
我现在就是怀着孕，
你们就得照顾我的感受，
照顾我的情绪。
因为我和我男朋友是在一起7年，
今年是25岁或今年是30岁，
我们两个在一起这么多年，
本来是打算今年年底见家长的，
但是由于七八月份查出来怀孕了，
我就一切都提前了，
所以我们8月3号就汇了亲家，
谈的就是他们家彩礼给20万，
再给10万块钱的婚宴钱，
所以一共是给30万，
我这边是考虑到首先我怀孕了嘛，
第二个我不想大办，
所以我就是这10万的婚宴钱，
我就不想大办婚礼，
那父母的意思呢，
就是说不管你大不大办，
这十万都给你家也挺满意的，
然后就说我们家呢，
出20万的陪嫁，
加上一辆车，
他自己的婚前财产呢，
他买的时候大概150万左右的房子，
我查了他的征信，
房子的贷款的话呢，
还有就是3万没有还完，
他有一辆大概市值30万的车，
贷款的话呢，
大概还有十几个没有还完，
加上他的车贷，
一共是欠了35万，
这35万呢，
一部分是车贷的钱，
一部分是疫情那两年他生病了，
加上没有出去工资，
我们两个在一起，
我来了，
这个存贷我觉得我也是有花的，
在疫情这个期间，
这个问题挺。
严重的就跟他商量这个事儿，
他就说这个让我放心，
就在房产证上加我的名字，
然后呢，
我就觉得可以，
就同意了，
同意了之后我们会见面的时候呢，
双方是各拿了10万块钱，
男方给了1万块钱的改口费，
我们家也给了1万块钱的改口费，
一共是22万。
今天呢，
我身体不舒服，
我没有去存这个钱，
我男朋友就把这个钱拿走去存到了他的卡里，
我心里就不太舒服，
我说那不管怎么样，
你这个钱你去转给我了，
他就先给我转到2万，
说是先把那个戒指的钱付了，
然后就跟我商量要不要去存你的定期，
我就感觉嘛，
后面我们两个还会收钱，
我说那就等一笔大额的我们一起存吧，
我就想转到我的卡里，
然后当时因为还有限额什么的，
说那也无所谓了，
反正就先放在你卡里吧，
但是这个事儿其实我自里就有点不舒服，
9月4号我们就领了账，
我刚才查了一下，
9月的5号，
9月6号，
9月22号，
他妈妈分别给我转了四万五两笔和51000笔，
一共给我转了14万，
就是还差这个8万块钱的彩礼没有给，
我问他呢，
他说是家里，
他们家是做小本生意，
就是说周转有一件问题，
所以说是在9月末之前给完案，
我们两个是9月27号办的那个答谢宴，
我们家就只收了10万块钱，
他们家共就来了两桌，
所以就是基本上没有这个婚宴的收入，
基本上都是我们家的，
这10万块钱在10月8号的时候，
他就想去存上，
我就说那你。
存在我的卡里，
因为当时我手里就是说实话没有什么钱了，
就是加上包克里这些，
然后他就说啊，
太麻烦了，
直接一起存在卡里吧，
我当时就很生气，
也是我也有问题，
没有跟他好好工作，
就是说我手里没有钱，
我就很生气，
我说这个钱是我父亲办婚宴给的钱，
为什么要存到你卡里，
然后我们两个因为这个事儿就开始吵架，
情绪上头嘛，
然后我就说你们家答应9月末之前给的彩礼，
现在还没给完，
现在已经10月8号了，
嗯，
不是因为钱跟你吵架，
我是因为这个事儿，
为什么就是一句回应都没有了，
你哪怕跟我说啊，
最近困难啊，
或者什么什么什么的这些也可以，
然后我就没有话，
我说，
而且三金的话我现在也没有见到，
我说哪有人结婚一个月的三金还没看到呢，
我就觉得挺难过的，
因为我觉得我是挺信任他们家的，
所以我同意你这个彩礼一笔一笔的在也会把钱存到他的卡里什么什么的，
半夜我就睡不着觉，
然后加上怀孕了嘛，
情绪比较激动，
我就哭，
也没有理我，
他就睡觉了，
第二天他说他要上班，
但在这之前我们俩的感情一直都很好，
9号我就回娘家的，
吵完家的第二天嘛，
我去之后呢，
我就肚子疼，
我就去医院检查，
可能就是有点情绪激动了，
我就回想这个事儿，
我就想啊，
我这个情况下，
我真的还要生这孩子嘛，
就说那如果你们家一点态度都没有，
你自己还要把所有的钱都存到你的卡里的话，
这个日子我没有办法过，
而且你之前答应的就是说什么婚后财产都归我管，
现在都存卡里，
然后他就说啊，
就是没觉得什么有这。
得我的，
反正咱俩都结婚了，
填谁的不都是一样的嘛，
只要你收，
我马上就会转给你，
我就还是觉得很生气，
因为我没有看到在家的彩礼，
然后晚上呢，
我就给他父亲打了个电话，
就问了一下这个彩礼的事儿，
然后也没有回应，
我就说白了，
那是人家妈妈，
他不会觉得他自己儿子不对，
他觉得是我是不是碰到点小事儿就要考虑离婚，
就要考虑打孩子，
昨天的话，
他们家把剩下的8万块钱给我了，
然后告诉我说他爷爷最近住院了，
但是挺严重的，
他父母都在那个医院里面，
没有在家，
这两天他就回去给我拿三金，
现在钱是都转给我了，
我现在手里一共是有35万三金，
说是这两天给我拿，
你18岁就跟他谈恋爱，
对，
就是这些年来，
他对我一直都很好，
包括家里的阿姨啊，
双方的父母啊，
都觉得很认可，
因为我脾气属于那种特别不好，
所以他呢就是可以一直包容，
而且包括花钱方面，
就比如说最近我这个要生孩子了，
她一个中心我就是送去了我们这边最好的一个，
但我没想到的那么贵，
大概是7万左右，
我老公跟我一起吃呢，
他就是没有任何意见，
是只要是你觉得可以对你身体好，
这4万块钱我们可以花，
我有的时候会觉得很割裂，
我想不明白为什么他跟我花钱的时候他很大方，
但是有的时候又会因为这个钱发生这么激烈的争吵，
我算一下账啊，
就是你家办那个婚宴的时候收了10万块钱，
然后之前呢，
又有20万存到你男朋友的卡里，
那照理来说，
这加起来就已经30万了呀。
对，
那后来你又说婆婆又给了8万，
刚开始那20万是他们家出了10万，
我们家出了10万，
后来婚宴的时候，
我父亲又给了我10万，
所以你手里现在存款一共是有多少35万，
因为我们办那个婚宴啊，
加上买戒指啊，
订影礼服啊，
这些东西都跑出了，
现在还一共剩35万，
就是他们家一共给了30万，
我们家一共给了20万，
钱都齐了，
其实总共是50万，
花掉了15万，
还剩35万是吧？
对的，
现在孩子几个月，
现在是四个月，
手上有35万，
也是挺有安全感的啊，
你是独生女吗？
都不是的，
娘家条件怎么样啊，
还可以，
比上不足，
比下有余，
手上有35万，
娘家条件也不错，
娘家能给出20万的这个陪嫁，
那条件相当好了，
这男的就是月子中心也挺大方的，
7万块钱月子中心你想住，
人家也答应，
也让住，
我感觉也愿意为你花钱呀，
对，
就是我们两个感情很好，
他一直给我花钱，
也非常大方，
我没有订那么贵的月子中心，
就大概定了一个三四万块钱了，
我想交钱，
我手里都没有钱了，
你就说为什么要把这些钱都存你卡上呢？
我现在手里已经没有钱了呀，
然后就是因为这个事儿放一下，
但是他平常呢，
对我又挺好的，
其实这事儿有的时候就是在前期就把规矩定好，
你这个做法其实没毛病，
是对的，
与其我自己心里面生闷气，
委委屈屈的，
我还揣着个孩子委委屈屈的去生气，
不如我有。
把丑话说在前面，
我就是没有安全感，
钱就是要存在我卡里，
我现在就是怀着孕，
你们就得照顾我的感受，
照顾我的情绪，
我感觉挺好的，
现在不是也达到这个效果了吗？
以后就这么干，
你想要什么放在明处说，
别老心里面委委屈屈，
就这事儿，
假设我一开始我就这么干，
从一开始我就不让他去存钱，
钱到我手上我就直接交我的化妆包里了，
我自己第二天我NNN我就去存钱了，
有这么多屁事儿呢，
就没那么多屁事儿了，
以后姑娘你就记住了啊，
就这么干，
想要什么自己直接干，
别等，
别靠，
别要，
就是想要什么上手就自己干，
干完了你别等他去存，
我自己存钱的方面，
我这么做是没有问题的，
对没，
其实说实话，
我有点不知道该怎么办，
然后这个事情打扰到现在也已经解决完了，
我不知道我做的有没有问题，
你做的没有问题，
该要钱就是要钱，
你们说了这个彩礼钱多少钱，
我打电话要没有毛病没问题，
可能我年纪比较小，
这个事儿发生之后，
我不太知道怎么去跟国家相处，
有主见以后一定要有主见，
要什么东西的话就摆明了说，
要怎么样的话摆了说，
不要老是猜，
老是说他们怎么怎么做，
行，
那我明白了，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
男人千千万万，
有的有的，
有家暴的，
有各种那个什么的，
他俩谈了七年了，
没有发现男方有什么不良的嗜好啊，
走啊什么的啊，
家暴啊什么的，
就算是个正常男人了。
人他都是自私的人，
他都有点小九九，
你想找一个说。
什么事都先替你想到了，
什么事儿就先顾及到你，
什么事儿都就先为你着想，
什么钱都存你卡里，
我跟你说现在就太难了。
他俩谈了7年，
虽然说男方是很拖沓，
有点小心思，
但最终结果是什么？
结果不还是钱都打到女方卡里了吗？
这就已经挺好的了，
这就已经可以了，
实实在在的男方出了30万，
女方出了20万，
现在实实在在钱都在女方卡里了，
这就已经很好了。
记得点赞关注哦。